hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
going to explain a 2022 Spanish mystery
movie called the chalk line
sometime at night Paula and her husband
Simon are driving home when Simon
suddenly spots something in the middle
of the road and alerts his wife to be
careful Paula stops the car and the
couple get out of the car finding a
Wandering girl who is following the road
marking as they approach her the girl
gets scared then runs into a speeding
bike the motorbike attempts to dodge the
girl and crashes off the road they
immediately rescue the girl while
surprisingly ignoring the dying Rider
they bring them into a hospital where
the doctor explains that she's in a very
sick condition not long after the
detectives arrive questioning the couple
about the girl's background but they
don't know anything about her in the
morning the couple finally make it home
Paula immediately rushes into the
bathroom where she secretly injects some
medication to her belly then resets the
alarm for the subsequent dose it seems
like she deliberately tries to hide it
from his husband still that day Paula
and Simon return to the hospital Dr
Gloria tells them that the girls muted
and her kidney function is low but she
assumes that her name is Clara after she
reacts strongly when a nurse with the
same name is being called as they reach
Clara's room they hear the girl
screaming in pain but the nurses can't
understand her Paula immediately
intervenes and hugs Clara to calm her
down inside a chalk box which is
successful that evening the couple
joined a dinner hosted by their
neighbors Claudia and Beltran where
Paula and Simon share about Clara's
condition Maite and her husband Eduardo
also present there the following day the
couple visited Clara in the hospital
figuring out that she's tied up and has
been heavily sedated as her Health's
condition is worsening the doctor asks
them to leave the couple is worried
about her and since they still can't
find any information about her parents
they plan to temporarily adopt her Dr
Gloria also thinks that's the best way
to establish a connection with Clara to
help her recover so she agrees with it
that night they finally bring Clara home
learning from the incident at the
hospital Paula realizes that she must be
surrounded by chalk lines so she draws a
rectangle around her bed to make her
feel safe the following day Clara wakes
up trying to adapt with her new room
Paula even prepares a breakfast for her
and attempts to form a deeper bond with
the girl soon Paula does an experiment
using a plant pot to learn more about
Clara's uniqueness she discovers that
the girl will be okay as long as she
does not pass the chalk boundaries the
couple decide to draw a path along the
house so that she can move freely the
next day Dr Gloria comes to the house to
check on Clara's condition
she forces the girl to step over the
chalk line and tells the couple to wait
in the kitchen as soon as Gloria erases
the line Clara begins to scream in pain
and speaks for the first time she
repeatedly shouts the word buma until
Paula can't take it anymore and decides
to intervene to calm her down afterwards
they continue the session where Gloria
asks her about the word she spoke before
but she refuses to talk instead Clara
Whispers some phrases to Paula to which
the women can't understand as time goes
on Clara begins to feel safe around
Paula after that Paula and the others
gather again for another neighborhood
meeting when they're eating together
Eduardo volunteers to get a glass for
Paula in the kitchen next day Claudia
brings her daughter to play with Clara
but it does not go well when Claudia
Eats toast bread with Jam she suddenly
chokes on something she pulls out a
glass Shard from her throat which they
assume comes from the jam Simon
discovers that the lines very close to
the fridge implicitly assuming that the
girl is the culprit but but Paula
immediately disagrees the neighbors are
seen outside the house discussing the
accident which makes Paula worried
shortly after Simon comes to his wife
telling her that one of the words the
girl said earlier was written in a chalk
box the couple with the assistance of
Gloria continued translating the words
until they find out that they are German
there's still one unrevealed word but
the doctor immediately calls the police
hoping that they can find her parents
Paula asks Clara whether she's a German
but she ignores her and continues
solving puzzles as she tries to dig
deeper about her background she suddenly
gets distracted by a loud sound of her
washing machine she checks the machine
finding that it's overflowing because of
a set of keys inside of pants Paula
returns to the room but the girl
suddenly goes missing She searches all
over the house discovering that the main
door is left open Paula attempts to
search outside the house but to no avail
however when she returns in panic she
finds out that the girls with Simon
Paula thinks that she hid from her but
Clara says nothing she asks her what
buma is the last word they still can't
figure out the meaning of Paula
threatens to erase the line if she
doesn't give a response but she Rebels
at the same time she realizes that
Eduardo was observing from his place a
few moments later Dr Gloria comes by to
question the couple about the glass
incident afterwards Clara comes in and
shows Paula a drawing of seemingly like
a house frustrated that she's unable to
interpret the drawing Clara rips the
paper out and walks away Gloria
concludes that Clara is not progressing
at all and decides to take her back from
the couple Paula still doesn't give up
and keeps trying to translate the boom
award unfortunately as she eventually
figures out the meaning she suddenly
chokes on a piece of broken glass after
she drinks the milk from the fridge she
barely manages to pull out the broken
glass when she comes out of the bathroom
Clara disappears again with the main
door left wide open this time Paula
calls the police the detectives believe
that Clara ran away on her own but she
strongly disagrees with it the next day
the neighbors gather at the couple's
house when Claudia mentions that she'll
give birth earlier than expected Paula
suddenly gets triggered and expels
everyone from the house shortly after
Simon finally speaks up about his wife
secretly injecting medication turns out
that all this time Paul is having
trouble conceiving and they decided to
take a break from all the treatments but
she broke the agreement the husband
confesses that he purposely brought
Paula home to fix their relationship but
it seems that the presence of the girl
only makes it worse when silence away
Paula gets a call from Clara immediately
reporting it to the police at the police
station the detectives traced the call
and reveal that the call was made from
Paula's phone thus they think that Paul
is having some mental problem upon
completing the medical examination she's
allowed to go home as Paula leaves she
steals a file consisting of crime
against children cases in Germany while
reviewing the documents carefully she
comes across a case of a 12 years old
girl named Ingrid and accidentally finds
a photo with the same origami that Clara
made earlier in their house Paula
approaches the responsible forensic
pathologist to gather more information
after begging several times the doctor
reveals that the victim's kidneys were
no longer functioning Paula continues
surfing on the internet finding origami
with a similar shape that Clara made on
the victim's house arriving at home she
rushes over to Clara's room and finds
the same origami on the window she
examines Clara's previous drawing and
eventually discovers that it depicts
Eduardo's house from the window again
she sees Eduardo observing her from his
house the mystery is finally solved
Paula immediately reports to the police
that Eduardo might be the prime suspect
in Claris disappearing case after
hanging up the phone she proceeds to go
to Eduardo's house moving to Eduardo's
perspective it's revealed that he's the
one who put Clara on the road because
she's sick he also instructed her not to
talk before leaving her alone that night
during the neighborhood dinner he
deliberately broke glass and inserted
the shards into the jar and milk bottle
after that he sneaked into Simon's house
in an attempt to kidnap Clara throwing
the keys into the washing machine before
he managed to escape Simon returned home
so he left her and ran away the man is
actually a psychopath even his own wife
is afraid of him it's also him who
ordered Maite to trigger Paula by
mentioning her pregnancy he used this
opportunity to grab Paula's phone and
make the call then returning it without
getting caught back to the present Paula
arrives at the Psychopaths house using
the excuse of wanting to borrow a map
Eduardo becomes suspicious of her but
still complies with the request when the
woman is about to leave the door is
locked and Eduardo attacks Paula with a
hammer he then drags the woman into a
basement where Clara is staying all this
time he locks her up in another room and
restrains him to a pole moments later
the police knock on the door but the
mess has been entirely clean coming back
to the basement Eduardo interrogates
Paula who confesses that he's found
Ingrid from the document she stole
earlier while the psychopath is away
Paula manages to open the door and pass
the chalk to Clara asking her to be
brave and make her own way out meanwhile
after searching in Paula's house Eduardo
finally finds the evidence he returns to
the basement but cannot find the girl
there the enraged psychopath rummages
all over the place fortunately Clara
manages to reach the door and lock the
adults inside the basement she keeps
drawing a path for escape until she's
stuck at the main door of the house left
with no option Clara forces herself to
walk past the chalk line for the first
time in her life she manages to walk a
few steps and screens for help but
Simon's talking on the phone not paying
attention at the window bad luck for her
Maite finds the girl and takes her back
to the house in the morning Maite
suddenly is not afraid of his husband
anymore stating that she'll finally have
the freedom she deserved in her life but
Eduardo ignores her soon as the
husband's enjoying his breakfast Maite
opens the main door and several officers
break into the house arresting Eduardo
and freeing the women sometimes later
Paula calls Clara who sent back to
Germany where she lives with her
grandparents who's actually Ingrid's
parents it's also revealed that Paula is
finally pregnant
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching